every year now we get a superhero phone
from samsung this year it's batman so
this is the batman edition galaxy s7
edge
so obviously this phone looks really
sick but if we put it aside we get a
little bit more on the box there is a vr
headset in here which explains why the
box was so much bigger this is a full
black themed version of the newest gear
vr that samsung galaxy s7 edge is
compatible with nice and there's also
this plastic batman case which is a
pretty nice touch it has some depth to
it for sure
and then a little bit of paperwork and
underneath that you have your fast
charging accessories which i would have
thought would be the black and gold
theme but they're not and then you also
get a pair of samsung headphones which i
thought would be the black and gold
theme again but they're not and you also
get a sim card ejector tool as well
anyway here's the phone itself in all
the stealth black batman themed glory
why they always put the sticker here on
the back right in the middle i will
never know but once you get rid of it
you can admire the phone in all its
detail i thought iron man was actually a
pretty cool look last year if you
remember that with the red and gold all
over it but i guess batman might be the
perfect superhero to do a smartphone
with because you can just go stealth
black and that's exactly what samsung
did here with the black metal rails and
the black buttons and the whole black
edges this thing is murdered out from
top to bottom and then it has these
little bits of gold accents that you can
see like the ring around the home button
and the bit of gold and the earpiece and
the gold around the camera and the flash
cutout basically anywhere where you'd
previously seen glossy silver it is now
gold and then of course you get the gold
batman logo on the back oh and once you
boot it up just like laster you'll also
see there is with this phone custom
software you get a batman injustice
theme right out the box obviously you
can disable this one right off the box
or if you plan on using a stock theme
you can do that as well like if you
actually use this phone as your daily
driver but yeah it's all in there and
not gonna lie it's not the prettiest
software theme i've ever seen
but at least they stay consistent with
the wallpapers and the batman black and
gold theme to match the precious
hardware you're holding you get that
animated lock screen with the wind sort
of blowing through batman's cape you get
that full icon pack and then black and
gold everywhere you'd expect to see
colors changed in a theme notifications
settings etc even the always-on display
which is new to the galaxy s7 shows the
date the time and a faded batman logo
just for good measure i actually think
that's pretty sweet but yeah galaxy s7
edge was already a pretty unique phone
to begin with and i mean we talked about
how other phones all look so similar to
each other nowadays but galaxy s7 edge
with the glass front and the dual curved
edges and glass back
it was kind of already a unique phone
but this just kind of takes it to the
next level with a fresh coat of paint
literally feel free to drop a thumbs up
if you'd cop this one samsung doesn't
have to keep doing these superhero
edition designs and custom packages but
i'm glad they keep doing it so keep it
up samsung this one i'm holding is
number 396 of only 1 000 of these that
they will ever make and i'm giving it
away so feel free to follow on twitter
for a shot at this 1200
super limited edition smartphone pretty
soon after this video i'll make a post
it'll be super easy to get in on winning
this internationally again thanks for
watching this quick video on the batman
galaxy s7 edge and i'll talk to you guys
in the next one
peace